ciao ragazzi bentornati una nuova
puntata di cucina adottata oggi faremo
le big bubble ci credo non esista ma
come bravo però mi piace questo tipo di
reazione da parte del nostro pubblico in
realtà è piuttosto semplice fare queste
come da masticare
la cosa difficile è trovare gli
ingredienti infatti per me è stato un
pochino tosto tanto che alla fine ho
dovuto ordinare un kit online pur di
riuscire a ottenere questa roba qui sono
impazzito partiamo subito con gli
ingredienti per fare le big babol avete
bisogno di gomma base zucchero a velo
sciroppo di glucosio bellissimo non so
se lo vedete non puoi farlo
questa roba che può essere male
interpretata in realtà solo a roma di
ciliegia oa roma di uva le big babol
hanno una roma di fragola ma io adoro la
roma d'uva prima possibile assaggiare
che abbiamo che mix fare ma che non
stiamo facendo frequente il big bubble e
infine colorante alimentare rosa proprio
come quelle dei più bubble
se io posso a bagnomaria far andare
questa roba qua dentro che resiste ma
che vanta è come faccio a chiuderlo la
pellicola in frigo nel microonde
vogliamo provare a vedere che succede
anche resistenza quando utilizzabile a
temperature superiori a 150 gradi per
più di 30 minuti e quindi va alla grande
mettiamo la gomma a galleggiare nel
frattempo cerchiamo di ammorbidire
questo cosino qui questo quest'anno qui
si ammorbidisce sempre mettendo un
pochino in acqua calda dai questa sta
diventando molto più morbido affidati
dai schiaccia lo fa vedere
sembrano droga verde gas e ma che stiamo
facendo una puntata di gomorra sa di un
odore
questo è ciriani ha fatto le due testate
di bubble ciliegia o ragazzino non ci si
deve il grembiuli grembiule
quindi fondamentalmente come dobbiamo
fare è aspettare che si sciolga la gomma
unirla nostro glucosio che stiamo
facendo ammorbidire ma che qui si sta
sciogliendo perché altrove di quanto è
gonfio e inutile che fingiamo sto
facendo queste ingredienti naturali ma
non metalli da questo sia naturale mi
sembra tutto finto
non c'è niente al mondo che vorrei e più
di te io più di tutto quel che ha dell
fatto fra di noi perché io non ti
cambierei nemmeno per nemmeno per un
miglio a proposito di milioni ragazzi ci
siamo quasi è anne e meravigliosa questa
cosa bisogna anche delle persone
ringrazio nuovo quando fanno le cose
capito grazie bisogna ringraziare in
generale per questo enorme crescita di
questo ultimo periodo sono veramente
contento grazie mille bravo ha fatto
bene però ho fatto capire di essere
persone del fuoco l'osso video tornerai
su un po confuso posso dirlo anche se
non lo dici che hai scelto e perché sono
una grandissima espressività lo so
fondamentalmente quando noi mangiamo una
gomma che in realtà noi consumiamo un
sacco di prodotti pieni di zucchero
io mi sento potente con questa tra le
mani quando parlo di
queste sagge voglio parlare
il tuo cuore voglio vivere per me di
sole e d'azzurro copyright
era molto simile all'originale ma
bisogna stare molto attenti a verona si
lentamente molto lentamente ma si
scioglie la virtus hope we belong fa che
questa natura possono pare infatti era
un sì vabbè a quelli per organo di
canzoni
beh non funziona proprio così si sono
tutte come lui
all
che è una cover molto bello
vale ne faccio un'altra ora vieni con me
verso un mondo di incanto principessa è
tanto che il tuo cuore aspetta non si
aprì gli occhi tra mille
non sono uno straccione solo un
poveraccio mai si sta sciogliendo dailan
in tema solitudine
marco se n'è andato e non ritorna più un
trio dei malesi modo tu sei timon e
quelle bomba biologica vito
si stanno innamorando il nostro trio
diventerà ma che carri beh un po brutto
da vedere museo aggiungere questo per
ora miss col dito non bruciano amino
così tanto sembra voldemort ap nascerà
il water 4
questo qui sì quando secondi se la tiri
e corrono non lo sa per il color ambra
indicata quando vedo questi usare a
bocca c'è nemmeno una ricetta dovremmo
aggiungere il sapore è quello tutto
questo masticare
certo che me lo aspetto
kill
è tutto un po mi dà
[Risate]
faccio qualcosa invece di arrabbiato in
tre arrabbiato arrabbiato
roberta tu sei esperta del mio cuore
esperta studiati the turano un'epica
cultura e metto zucchero a velo voglio
togliere il velo dai tuoi occhi perché
poi alla fine tumi sblocchi
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine perché
non è male
misti va dalla prima volta che ton ci
sta non volevi che ti parlassi adesso
che vinco se solo poker d assi
mandati una gomma non mi parlare adesso
se vuoi parlare con me facciamo solo
sesso
tengo dalla strada e lì sono rimasto
perché non sono già migliorando neo di
matrix ma paesi elencati
il margine stessa maglietta che ti fa e
non è grasso
no no cioè l'esatto 13 certo sembrava
quel mitico e quelle spalle ma sta
giudicare le persone allora aspetto che
i ragazzi mazza robbie kay tanto
criticato
venite anche voi ragazzi io faccio molto
volentieri
siete pronti cin cin cin diventano
pietre
[Musica]
la figlia mettere di meno ma ora è
diventata come simbolo alla fine le
uniche come che migliorano finendo ma è
la tua lingua e quello che si sente già
mezz'ora siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video nessuno riuscirà a fare un
palloncino
grazie grazie per averci seguiti come
sempre chiedo sempre piaciuto questo
video di iscrivermi gli lasciano
commento un pollice in su prevedere un
panello dove ci vediamo la prossima
domenica sempre alle 12 con un altro
episodio di cui si era buttata ciao
il nuovo ceo perché deve infilare la
lingua in un punto dove tutto tutto il
turno deve essere piero vinci a girare
il calcio più mi lascia la iniziata